Listen,
>> did you really say that I wouldn't stop
trying to stop you going out there?
>> I didn't say I didn't say that. I didn't
say that at all. I said that I would
obviously not let you go out by
yourself.
>> I didn't say that that you would
wouldn't try to stop me.
>> You're not going out of the [__]
house, right?
>> This is a [__] Yeah.
>> No, I'm going to [__] I'm going to
rage quit right now. I want to [__]
break up with you. Like I am. I'm not
I'm not joking. I'm serious. I will
break up with you.
>> What? Becket. Becket. Now's the chance
to call her blow.
I am hustling over the hall right now.
>> Hear me out.
>> So, I'm just getting some stuff through.
>> Looks like there's going to be some
armor. Let's go.
>> Anyway, another thing I also There's
this other girl. It might have been the
same one.
But, okay, thinking about I think I I
think I just started spuring about my
random like [__] autistic interest
to this [__] I I think I just started
[Music]
Is this kind of what you're getting at?
Am I Am I Am I being accurate here? Is
this good thoughts?
I mean, if if if their definition of
pedobating is getting the minor to get
abused or whatever, then sure. But when
I when I think of pedob baiting, I think
of, you know, go message this adult or
something. I'll give him beautiful green
green eyes. Look at this. Beautiful. So,
I don't know. I DM Al Malcolm about it.
I'll see if there's any any truth to
what they're saying.
>> Obviously, the audience on the kill
stream is going to be [__] loving
this. Why subject yourself to this? Just
say, "Not really appropriate. I'm not
going to do that." Yes, BPF is a lion
toying with a wounded gazelle. That's
what it feels like watching this. Crazy.
Utterly insanity.
>> In the mental gymnastics of this, unless
you've been in those situations, no.
Unless you've been in those situations,
like I've I've been in
>> like you realize you can say no to
things. You're allowed to say no, right?
And yeah, you'll get a bit of stick if
people think you're being a [__] But
you're better off saying no rather than
saying yes and this happening, which is
way [__] worse. Jesus Christ. And
it's not even like unreasonable. It's
not an unreasonable thing that you're
like, "Do you know what? I'm not going
to go on the kill stream and litigate
the details of what would happen if
someone came into the house and tried to
murder us." Yeah, I think I'm probably
going to give that a miss to be honest
with you.
>> Threatening situations as well. I've got
a fair idea how I'd act. That doesn't
necessarily mean that's how Hunter would
act or even the average person, right?
>> Yeah. Okay. So, what? That's not That's
not pertinent to my question. My
questions about you and Stardust, not
even doesn't even have anything to do
with Hunter. Just asking if the roles
were reversed, would you be the guy?
>> Yeah, I'd probably try and get her out
of the way of danger. Sure.
>> Yeah, that makes sense. But you don't
think it's cowardice that he didn't,
right, Becket?
>> Look, listen to his tone. He's taking
the piss were. But if Okay, look. He
didn't just leave her alone.
Dude, I can
>> This isn't like an hour. I feel like we
got a scout. I'm going to go like 10
more minutes.
>> Altern your girlfriend. Alternatively,
you need to say, "Nah, [__] this bitch."
That might work actually. Funny enough,
the gig chat I don't care about women
thing might work. Maybe that might piss
us off. I don't know. But like there's
no angle you've got with which you can
win. You're losing in one way or
another. The only way you can win is not
playing. That's it.
>> This time she's she's
>> trying to work out the logistics. And
I'm trying to remember back
>> like a hostile audience with an
interlocutor who is trying to just stir
whatever he's trying to
>> No, I know. Go. I'm saying I was told
there was pedo bay. I would not define
that as pedo bait. I messaged Malcolm
about it. I'll see if I can get like a
better clip
>> and also he's not doing it in a way that
undermines
>> or any evidence point because he knows
he's going to be to undermine what a
Stardust point
>> which is obviously going to make
Stardust look bad in this debate in
front of the hostile audience on the
kill stream and so on and so forth.
>> Honestly, a masterful gambit I must say.
>> [__] house is tie me up with and you
would not be able to stop me from coming
out the door behind you. I would of
course want you to stop and not even go
out in the first place, but if you're
insisting on going, there's no way in
hell I would let you go out by yourself.
I had your back. I want you. I want to
let you go.
>> Listen. Listen. If there was any
reasonable way that
>> you're in a relationship with me, not
with him.
>> Oh my god. Listen. Did you really say
that I wouldn't stop trying to stop you
going out there?
>> I didn't say I didn't say that. I didn't
say that at all. I said that I would
obviously not let you go out by
yourself.
>> I didn't say that I would that you would
wouldn't try to stop me.
>> She's not going out of the [__] house
right now.
>> This is a [__] Yeah.
>> No, I'm going to [__] I'm going to
rage quit right now. I won't [__]
break up with you. Like I am. I'm not
I'm not joking. I'm serious. I will
break up with you. What? Beck, now's the
chance to call her blow.
Listen,
I am humbling over the call right now.
>> Hear me out. No woman on planet Earth is
ever going to dump you because you say
that you're going to make her sit there
while you conf.
>> Okay, listen. I don't care if you e
date. I don't care if you date.
>> Not for me. Not for me. Unless I find
the one. Listen, if I find my soulmate
on Discord,
what stays in Vegas or what happens in
Vegas stays in Vegas. I get I don't
know. But like If you eate, sure. Okay.
If you if you if you require e- dating,
sure. Don't eate another content creator
as a content creator and then go on
streams with them. Holy [__] Holy [__]
That that is like insane. That is
[__] crazy. Don't do that. That
That's like That is a recipe for
disaster, dude. Liter Look at [__]
Look at [__] um Look at Turkey Tom.
Look what happened with Kai. Okay, that
was evil. That was evil. Okay. Aren't
you technically an e-ater? No, I have
never e- dated in my life that I know
of. Listen, if someone has some like
unconsensual thing, unconsensual e-
dating, I don't know. Listen, what I
mean, that's on them. But no, I don't e
date like another content creator and
then debate them on a live stream.
That's like a a massive recipe for
disaster.
>> I'm this close. I am this close.
>> No, no, it's all good. It's all good.
>> Fair enough. Fair enough. We can wrap.
We can wrap it here. It's all good.
>> BPF is a bit wild for pushing this.
That's just BPF. That's what he does.
Did you not see the [__] debate con
thing where we had a go?
>> Is Tinder not considered e dating?
>> Have fun with your husband. Oh, come on.
This is exactly as [__]
>> Probably not. No, I think that's like a
Probably not. I don't think
>> it's a thing, isn't it? I don't really
watch these Redpool podcasts, but I've
heard that he's been battering women.
I've heard it's been battering women as
well. When I went to look for some of
this earlier, I saw his YouTube channel
and it's all just him like [__] on
women
>> on what on the whatever podcast
>> based on I do want I do want to say one
thing because I think this is Listen, as
funny as it is, I think it's a red
[__] herring because while this is
all hilarious and it's a great little
[__] boyfriend in he'll reinforce my
point. The truth is I don't think this
is like accounting for cowardice. I
think this is just accounting for like
stupidity.
>> Oh yeah, then why wouldn't you do it?
Then why wouldn't you take your girl
with you? Why wouldn't you do it?
Because that's what a [__] coward
would do, right, Becket?
>> Well, it's okay. Listen, you can call it
cowardice if you like. I call it [__]
stupidity.
>> Maybe it's both. It' be stupid and
>> cowardice. It's not. No,
>> I don't. I don't.
>> She's so pissed off.
>> Like I genuinely wouldn't. The problem
the problem here is that the information
that they're working on is that it's her
exartner. I don't I don't think they've
been in a relationship very long. Like
it's what a couple of months if that.
You know, it's it's a radically
different situation to BPF was just
hammering home his points. The shitty
relationship getting fragged was just a
side benefit. What the [__]
I disavow.
I just think this this serves as a
lesson as to why you should try and
avoid. I mean, again, it's the classic
thing of, you know, having a publicized
relationship and being a little couple
that comes on stream. Give that a miss.
Avoid avoid avoidive.
>> True. Avoid that.
>> Um, it's it's firstly her actual ex
partner who she's been with for 11.
>> Tinder is mid random.
>> True.
>> The only I don't use any of those apps
anymore. I'm going to be honest. Dude, I
got banned from Hinge. I started I like
called this girl like a [__] [__]
on Hinge and then got banned. It was
very bleak after that. Nothing. It It
all just felt kind of numb, you know,
after that. It all just kept felt kind
of numb. I kind of just didn't care
anymore. Works like a charm. It didn't.
She got really mad. She wrote me this
She wrote like I I I I said some comment
and then she got like snippy with me and
I was like, "Dude, you're like a
[__] bitch." I was joking or
something like that and then she wrote
this like massive paragraph and then I
was like you're [__] you're stupid or
something. It was something like that. I
said a joke and then she got mad and
then I called her [__] and then she
wrote a massive paragraph and then I
continued to dismiss her and then she
reported my account and again got me
banned. I don't remember the specifics.
I think I might have screenshots of it.
Hold on. How long ago would this have
Let me see if I I'd have to scroll down
super long. On
Hold on, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I
might I might. I might. I might. I
wonder what this would have been. I took
screenshots cuz I thought it was really
funny. Know I Is it worth it to like
scroll through my [__] phone to try
to find this [__] I don't even know.
Oh, is this a Catboy dig? Yeah, I'm more
I'm more curious about what I said to
her that what I what cuz I I insulted
her. I called her like a [__] [__]
or something and she got really mad.
Listen, this might be a losing battle. I
don't know if I'm seeing it. Oh, this is
not it. I keep getting excited thinking
I found it. I'll find it. I'm sure. I'm
sure. I'm positive or something. I'm
positive. They call me positive Patrick.
That's what they call me. That's what
they've been calling me for a while now.
That's what they've been calling me for
a while now is positive Patrick. I don't
know if you guys have been knowing this,
but they have actually been calling me
Positive Patrick. I remember trolling
old men on Tinder. I got to see one of
their boobs. Okay, well that's
interesting. I feel like that's one of
those things that you would just take to
the grave. You know,
that's just me.
I don't know when this would have been.
I'm digging, dude. I'm [__] digging.
I feel like I'm getting close. My gut is
telling me I'm getting close.
My gut is telling me I'm getting close.
Hold on. Brace. Brace. I've like never
deleted any screenshots that I've taken
on this phone. It goes back to like the
day that I got this [__] I need to like
delete the [__] pictures on my phone.
There's like so much just like it's like
[__] memes and like um
like I would screenshot [__] I would
find and just send it to my friend like
look at that this is funny and then just
never delete it. It's like a bunch of
it's like dude I have so why did I took
so many screenshots of my like Clash of
Clans base. There's like 50 of them.
Why? What the [__] There's like act
dude I keep scrolling up and there's
more. Why did I take so many pictures of
my Clash of Clans base? [__] Is this
it? Oh, dude. I was so mean. What the
[__] I found it. Holy [__] I don't
even know if I want to read this out. I
was really mean. Okay. I They sent me a
massive I was really r Okay, I was
meaner than I thought. I sent the last
message I sent to them. They sent me
this um this massive paragraph and then
I said, "Bro thinks I'm reading all of
that." And then they reported me and
unfriended me or whatever. How however
it works on [__] however it works on
Hinge. Sorry. Oh, dude. This doesn't
seem like communication. I don't think
I've insulted you at all. I think it's
pretty telling that you default to
insults when a conversation isn't going
somewhere you like. Are you usually this
aggressive slash negative? Just curious.
Smile. Why was I so rude?
Why was I so rude? Why was I so mean?
What the [__] Why was I so mean to this
person? I don't even know what they did
to piss me off. I was just so mean.
Jesus. I called her bad faith. Dude,
this is wretched. She should have She
should have unmatched. Holy [__] This
is wretched [__] Oh my god. What the
[__] No, I don't even know if I want to
read this [__] out. This is bleak. This
is bleak [__] This is bleak [__] Oh my
god.
This is terrible. This is terrible. I
was so mean. Holy [__] What the [__]
dude? I feel like we could have an
amazing discussion about this. However,
I feel as if you're going through this
conversation extremely bad faith. Would
you say that's true? And then they send
me five paragraphs and then I respond,
"Bro thinks I'm reading all that." Dude,
maybe it was a good thing I was banned
off hinge. Maybe it was a good thing I
was banned off hinge.
Maybe it was a good thing I was banned
off hinge. Jesus, that that was I I did
not think that was that bad. I was
really nasty to this girl. Jesus Christ.
You're having a bad week. Maybe banned.
Yeah, I got banned. This is like I'm
just like reading this over like this is
why why was I so mean and vile to these
women, dude? So mean and vile and [__]
up. Mean and vile, twisted, [__] up
psychopath. And then I'm screenshotting
my Borderlands 2 build. Dude, what have
I screen? It's like Clash of Clans
bases, Spotify songs,
Borderlands 2, and Battleblock theater
forum posts.
What? Why? I don't even remember the
[__] Facebook listing for a truck. Why
was I looking for a truck? Um, okay. I
took a screenshot of the stock market.
Beautiful. Another Clash of Clans base.
Cool. What the [__] Why? I'm so Dude,
this is terrible. All right, let's get
back to this. I guess I guess we've
learned that I'm um I'm really mean to
women and also I really like Clash of
Clans. I guess I don't know what I was
supposed to gain from that. I was really
rude and vile though [__] person. Um
and also Hunter is in the position where
he's been dragged into somebody else's
life drama which is which is which is
radically
>> Okay, I'll just open the Discord up.
Rise has done this. What is this, dude?
That is
>> That is unbelievable. I cannot believe
you've drawn this. This is shocking.
That's disgraceful.
>> Different. And what I'd ask you is this.
>> Yeah. Go ahead.
>> Okay. You're calling Hunter Roward and
everything else, but he didn't just
[__] jump over the balcony and try
and escape.
>> Um
>> Well, I mean, that's because it was a
two-tory drop, probably.
>> Do you not know how to talk to women? Um
I talk to women, I think, the same way I
talk to men. Bank. I get really mean
when I think a woman is like [__]
though, like more so than a man. If I
think a woman is [__] I get really
rude. There was this one time there was
this girl who like uh who who like she
was like a really big fan of the the
Silent Hill 2 remake and I tried to ask
her why and I I remember thinking her
reasoning was like really stupid. So I
started like insulting her and I was
like the original game's actually
better. And I I I like wrote this
paragraph explaining to her why the
remake was bad and why it was like a
soulless cash grab. Um, and I was just
being really rude to her because she she
liked the remake of Silent Hill 2. Uh,
and I forgot I forgot exactly how the
conversation ended. Um, but it did not
we stopped talking after that is is the
gist. The gist is we we stopped talking
after that. What race? She was white, I
think.
White or white passing? It just made it.
Dude, I [__] hate the Silent Hill 2
remake, dude. I [__] hate the Silent
Hill 2 remake. I could literally go on
for hours about why that game is so
[__] god awful and so [__] [__]
Holy [__] it's so bad. Jesus Christ.
Whatever.
>> I won't get into that on this stream.
Okay,
>> that really the whole thing ends here
with it. If your best friend, your best
pal,
>> are you gonna play Silent Hill F? [__]
no. That game looks dog [__] [__] no.
>> The same exact situation and you talk to
him afterwards, the very first thing I
would be, you stupid [__] Why'd
you let that chick go out with you? Why
did you go out? But at the very least,
why the [__] did you let your woman go
with you? And he'd be like, "Oh, fuck."
And he would say, "You're [__] dumb
and you're a sissy." That's what would
happen.
>> But we didn't even disagree on this,
Andrew. We both agree that they both
shouldn't have gone out in the first
place.
>> Yeah, but is it cowardice that he had to
drag his chick with him
>> in order to go check on a threat? That'd
be like me waking my wife up in the
middle of the night. It'd be like me
waking up in the middle of night and my
wife's like, "I heard a noise
downstairs." And I'm like, "Okay, I'll
check it out." You're coming with me,
right?
>> Wait, wait, wait, Andrew. We don't know
that that's what happened.
>> We don't We do. We do have the timeline
of this because we don't have the No, we
don't have the conversation of him
saying, "Hey, do you want to come with
me?"
>> Why? Why was she with him?
>> We don't know.
>> Well, because they he got a call while
he's in the apartment. He got the call
explaining that there was somebody
lurking around, right? And he said that
he went to check it out and she went
with him.
>> Yeah.
>> So, we do know. The thing is that yeah
because he didn't say no [__] you're
staying here that's why it happened any
other way. How else could it have
happened? She was like she had a gun and
was coming with you.
>> I think that's perfectly [__] normal
for plenty of relationship. Just because
I would act in that situation in that
way doesn't doesn't mean plenty of other
men would.
>> Are you checking out the threat in the
middle of the night with Stardust? Come
on, dude. No, you're not. You are not.
>> You're really going to act like I would
let you go by yourself somewhere.
>> You're really going to act like you have
a choice?
>> Yeah, I do.
>> Look, but I think but I think
>> Okay, he's winning. Andrew Wilson's
epic. Sorry.
>> Yeah, this is the problem they're having
as well. But you're accepting the
premise of like the hunter situation in
relation to your circumstance and this
theoretical situation that you're going
to be in. Like you're probably better
off clarifying women. Dude, there was
this girl. I met her on like Bumble or
something and um we went we went on a
date. We went to this restaurant. It or
like this burger place. I I restaurant
makes it sound way too fast. It was like
this local burger place and we went to
like see um we went to like a walk or
something after to like this park. Okay.
And I remember like we were talking for
about a week and we were calling and I
forgot why, but the conversation turned
to like uh video games and she was like,
"Well, what's your what's one of your
favorite video games?" I was like, "Oh,
Fallout 2." And she's like, "Oh, tell me
about it." And I remember distinctly
going on like like a 30 minute or 40
minute walk or ramble like rant about
Fallout 2. And I wouldn't like I
wouldn't let her interrupt. I wouldn't
let her talk. I was just talking to her
about why Fallout 2 is so good. Um,
and after that things were never really
the same between me and this girl. I
don't think she liked it.
I don't think she liked it. I don't
think she enjoyed my my little ramble.
She she was not pleased by my con my
talk about Fallout 2.
Uh, it did not it did not go that that
relationship did not go anywhere after
after the Fallout 2 discussion,
unfortunately.
>> I mean, first of all, it's it's just I
don't think there's enough information
hard facts video footage or something
like that. All you've got is people's
words on what happened.
>> Are you diagnosed situation?
>> Not that I know of.
>> So, I'm just getting some stuff through.
Looks like there's going to be some
Let's go. Okay. Anyway,
>> another thing I also There's this other
girl. Or it might have been the same
one.
Okay, thinking about I think I I think I
just started spuring about my random
like [__] autistic interest to this
[__] I I think I just started rambling
about me to this girl. I was like, what?
I was I started talking about like the
the different yeasts that that is that
you can use to make me like the
different breeds of yeast. I'm thinking
I think this was the same girl. I kind
of realize now why why that relationship
never went anywhere. I don't think she
cared about about the yeast and the the
alcohol content and stuff like that.
Thinking about it, I'm I'm reminiscing.
I'm pondering. I'm thinking I I I might
I might I might have an inkling of a
clue as to why that that relationship
maybe fizzled out.
>> We shall see. Um but yeah, in this
situation, who who knows what happened.
Um, you know, obviously I think that the
idea that you would go out and check and
then also bring a partner with you is
absurd and I don't think any man worth
his salt would come on and go, "Yeah,
that's a good thing to do." You know,
you would either say I, if you were kind
of a bit more masculine minded, you
might say, "I'd go and check for
myself." Um, you know, alternatively,
you might just say, "I'd just call the
police because they're the people that
deal with that shit." And that would
probably also be acceptable. But the
problem is, I'm guessing that Stardust
has pushed this idea in order to defend
Hunter that she would make it so she had
to go. But then him coming on and saying
this just doesn't mind it, right?
>> Jada Pinket. What is a Jada Pinket?
>> Yeah. Maybe like again I think women
should be firearm trained like my mom
was like this when we were in South
Africa. My dad is not a great shark. It
was my mom who was like the [__]
shooting uh like to chase off robbers.
Women are absolutely capable of
defending themselves with firearms. I I
don't know if I completely agree with
the narrative of it should only just be
the man. You're asking what I would do,
but that's not necessarily normative.
>> Well, I feel like I have made my case
and have completed my case and I have
nowhere else to go.
>> I think you're attributing I think
you're attributing to cowardice and bad
decisionm.
>> All I need to know is how you would
react in the situation. I know that the
acting
to that you would consider to be [__]
That would be you would consider him to
be a [__] worse. Becky, come on.
>> Okay. Well, let's let's ask the other
question then. Isn't is the first
response to this like why is it just to
like I kind of don't get over this [__]
because this is obviously quite a [__]
>> Yeah, it's Conrad at the end of the day.
It's Conrad who is responsible for Holly
getting shot.
>> Nobody's taking nobody is making the
claim to the contrary. We can walk and
chew bubble gun at the same time. We can
say that there's no justification for
somebody to show up and do something
like
the things which led up to it and the
behavior that was enacted during it. We
can do both things. We can say both.
>> Stand back and stand by a loggers.
>> Tell you which ones are the most wrong.
It was the most wrong what that guy did.
>> Under the impression, right, Andrew, but
under the impression that they didn't
think that Conrad would be showing up
with a gun. They maybe thought that he
would show up, but not with a gun. Under
that impression,
>> who cares if they showed up with a bat
or because they under that impression it
is perfectly reasonable that she wanted
to come along with him.
>> Oh, I see. Okay. If that's fair, then if
that's your actual argument, then Becky,
if it was just a guy showing up with a
baseball bat, would you go confront him
with Stardust then?
>> We don't know that he has a baseball
bat. We
>> No, right. You don't know. But I mean,
assuming whatever he has, even if it's
just his fit, I mean, it shows up with
his bare hands, right? Why in the world
would Becket take him?
>> The smartest thing would have been, we
agree, the smartest thing would have
been for them to stay in their apartment
and call the police.
>> And the most courageous thing, and you
said this earlier, that you would have
considered if Hunter had gone out and
confronted him by himself and the guy
had had shot Hunter. You would have
considered that to have been a
courageous act. Those words came out of
your mouth.
>> [__] stupid. But they're courageous.
And that's why I say
>> I mean, an act can be courageous and
stupid, right? Okay. Like if there's a
horde of locusts in your store stealing
a bunch of stuff and you decide to
confront them and they shoot you in the
head dead, that is a very courageous
thing to do, but you've just been shot
dead over $1,000 of [__] merchandise.
Like, you know, why would you [__] do
that? That's stupid, right? Yes. Courage
and stupidity go hand in hand. Exactly.
So, yeah, obviously just going out.
Imagine just going out. Well, listen
here, mister. I don't like what you got
to say. Blow the [__] away. Obviously,
if you're going to be courageous,
there's a chance you're going to get
hurt doing that. So, probably probably
best to avoid that eventuality. Yeah,
>> that's what a [__] is. The opposite of
what's
>> here. I I I need I'm back on the woman
thing. Okay. Back on the woman thing.
Back on the woman thing. Listen,
this is a this is a DM exchange I had on
Bumble. Okay, this is like a couple
months ago.
This person says, "I'm trying to learn
how to play guitar. Maybe you could help
me." Listen, man. I'm kind of in it, but
I can try. Honestly, I just don't know
what else to say. What does this mean?
Am I [__] What does this mean? I
was like, "What do you mean?"
And then she just didn't respond. I was
like, "Huh? What the [__] What does
this mean? Am I [__] Am I
autistic?" Guys, I need you to tell me.
Okay. Why did she ask?
Because I'm an epic musician. Okay.
Musician is is making me out to seem way
more awesome than I am. Okay.
You should have gone with it. How do I
go with it? What does She just says, "I
don't know what else to say." What does
this mean?
What does this mean?
What does she mean? She doesn't know
what else to say about what? What? Huh?
Hello?
Huh? She's [__] Okay, this is good
to know. I'm still scrolling through all
the [__] screenshots I've taken, and
this is one of them. I I I remember I
remember distinctly I sent this to to to
a p to an individual and I was like am I
autistic? Am I [__] dude? Am I like
dumb as [__] What what the [__] does
this mean? What I don't understand what
this means. I don't get it, man. I
really don't get it. I have a screenshot
of a tomato soup recipe. Dude, I I don't
remember taking any of these. Jesus. A
lot of Okay, this is when I downloaded
Pokemon. a lot of screenshots of like um
of like Pokemon cards now. Will you
All right. Well, let's watch a If this
doesn't get like funny, I'm probably
going to end stream. I'm going to be I'm
tired.
>> Just because something that you do is
something you can do is courageous
doesn't mean that by not doing that
thing means you're a coward.
>> Okay. So, do stupid thing makes you
brave. Do doing stupid thing makes you
brave or is it is it brave because
you're doing the self-sacrificial thing?
You should have offered to bring her to
your place for private lessons and a
little something else. That that feels
like sexual harassment. What the [__]
What the [__] That I don't feel like
that would have ended well. That's like
what, bro? Say you can give her private
lesson. Dude, this just feels like
sexual harassment. What the [__] No,
it's Riz.
Oh, really? I It doesn't feel like it.
It doesn't feel like it. I don't know.
>> That feels evil
>> because she did the self-sacrifice,
>> right? But it was also really [__]
stupid.
>> She's literally asking for She's asking
to be raped. What are you talking about?
>> Burning, isn't it?
>> No.
>> That's what the app is for. Is I don't
>> for sexual harassment. What? No,
I just kind of talk to people. I don't
really say I I don't know.
I just kind of talk to people. When
people ask me to meet up like in like
the second day or like the third day of
talking to me, I I usually am like, "No,
I don't want to." That's stop like, "No,
I don't really know you. Sorry."
Wait. Okay. That makes Am I No. I Yeah.
No. No. I'll stand on that. No.
Generally, if if a girl is like on
Bumble or whatever, they're like, "Can I
meet up with you? Can I meet up with
you?" I'm like I I tell them no. I'm
usually like, "No, I don't want to.
I don't use the app like that. I usually
just talk to people. I usually try to I
my my go-to line is asking if someone
likes um it's like some genre of video I
forget. I'm like, "Do you like video
games?" Basically, I just want I just
want friends to play video games with
basically is is the gist is basically
how I use that app. Okay. Is basically
how I use that app. I try to find
friends to play video games with and it
obviously does not lead to many avenues.
I end up either debating them and
calling them bad faith
or apparently not sexually harassing
them enough. I don't know. I don't know.
I don't understand.
>> Are they trained to breathe in smoke,
Becket? Are they trained for that?
>> No, that's why they've got respect. I'm
not saying it's not I'm not saying it's
not dangerous, but it's worlds of
different.
>> You're horrendous.
I Is this even that egregious? This
feels I don't know. You guys are I feel
like you guys are blowing this out of
proportion. Why the [__] are you wasting
girls times?
They're on the app. They choose to
message me. How am I wasting them their
time?
How am I wasting their time? They they
they matched with me. They obviously
want to talk to me, right? That not
that's not what the app's for. Yeah,
that is they they matched with me.
Okay. I don't understand. How am I
wasting their time? Cuz they want to
[__] not talk. What?
Well, obviously I'm not interested in
that. I wouldn't want to
I wouldn't want to.
I remember some girl
some girl on like the first date tried
to kiss me and I like backed up and I
was like, "Sorry, I got to go." And then
I just walked home.
Listen, I I know I know what I I know
what I want and it's mostly like to talk
about video games and to talk about
music. That's generally speaking the
gist of uh what I'm interested in. And
if it if you do not give me that, I'm
more I'm not super interested. I'm not
super interested.
You are gay, dude. I'm not I'm not I'm
not gay.
I've actually I think I've I've said
this before on stream. I feel like there
is only one time a girl has asked for my
phone number in public and I if I I
remember I just I had headphones in uh
and I was I was standing at the checkout
of like a grocery store and she's like,
"Can I get your number?" And I just like
I pretended I couldn't hear her and I
like grabbed my cart and and walked
away. I didn't want to be rude and say
no. So I just like I just like looked
off into the distance and pretended I
couldn't hear her.
It was like it was so long. It was like
4 years ago. Had to be. I was like 18 or
something. It's only happened once. I
don't talk to people in public. I don't
like talking to people in public. It was
very awkward. I don't enjoy talking to
people in public. Public encounters are
like like random people. Not really. Not
really. How ugly. She looked fine, I
guess. I don't know. I just didn't want
to give some random person my phone
number. And I also didn't really want to
talk to her. I was at like the I was I
was at the [__] checkout of some
grocery store.
I was at the checkout of some [__]
grocery store and she's like, "Can I get
your number?" No. Ret. I'm like checking
I have like hot pockets and [__] in my
cart. I have like hot pockets and [__]
in my cart. What the [__] Why would I
want to? No, I'm not. No, I don't like I
don't like talking to like random people
in public unless it's like a
specifically like a social place like a
like a any anywhere but a grocery store
basically. Like no, I don't I'm not
there to talk to people.
I'm not there to talk to people. I'm
there to buy like hot pockets and bagels
and then leave. You need therapy. I
think I'm fine. What were you wearing? I
was wearing a sundress. My tits were
showing. Okay. My tits and ass were out.
I was basically asking for it.
I was basically asking for it. Okay.
Many have been saying you look subhuman.
I do. I kind of look like a I kind of
look like a thumb. I kind of look like
um like picture like Chris Evans but
like extraordinarily overweight. Like
Chris Evans crossed with Boogie 2988
is kind of what I look like. Picture
that in your head. Picture that. This is
a good bit.
I don't know, dude. I I feel like I
don't I don't understand the whole
hookup thing. Why would I want to hook
up with someone I just met? That's like
weird.
I also don't understand like the um like
I I would never go up to some random
girl and ask for their number. I would
expect someone to do the same to me.
That feels weird.
Maybe I'm just like so like socially
[__] Maybe I'm like socially inept.
Maybe I'm socially [__] I would
never do that. I think that's like weird
and uncomfortable. So, I would expect
someone to do the same to me. And then
when someone does that to me, granted,
it's only happened once. Um, it's just
like awkward. I'm like, uh, why? No, I
don't want to talk to you. You're being
a freak. You're like a freak, dude. I
don't know. I had I had like one
girlfriend when I was like, um, like one
one committed partner when I was like
19, 20. I think it was like a year or
two ago. And, uh, I think I think that
satiated me for a couple years. That
satiated me for a couple years. I think
I'll be fine for a while. I think I'll
be fine for a while not having a
relationship.
Imagine what hot people have to deal
with. I feel like I feel like it's the
same for everyone. I feel like most
people are just like I don't know. I
feel like it's normal to not want to
approach people in public. Maybe I'm
wrong.
I'm obviously not. It It seems like you
guys are disagreeing with me a lot here.
So, the only like Dude, it was epic. I I
we watched like the Batman, Robert
Patson Batman and Cyberpunk Edggerunners
and I uh I showed her how to play Slime
Rancher 2. Okay, that was the highlight.
That was that was the best part. I
enjoyed doing that. That was that was
the most epic part of it all. That was
the most epic part of it all. IMO people
are freaks when you're considered
attractive. Yeah. I'm glad I look like a
[__] mutant. I'm glad I look like a
[__] FEV subject. Okay. I'm glad I
look like a [__] that there was a a
steamroller, you know, rolled across my
head or something. Glad
I'm glad I'm an autistic mutant. Okay,
I'm actually glad about that. I'm
actually happy and joyous about that.
I'm trying to think, do I have any more
stories? Probably not. I do not live a
particularly interesting life. I think
that's like the highlight of my uh my
teens to 20s. People are nice and kind
to me. I try to be nice in public. Like
I'll say thank you. I say thank you.
Thank you. Smile
and I walk away. Pretty kind. I'm a kind
individual, I would say. I'm like
pondering. I'm pondering silently. I
can't be polite to men making me feel
unsafe when I'm alone. Dude, you're like
begging to be like [__] killed and
put into a barrel. What are you talking
about? What? Can't be polite to men
threatening to rape me. Okay, you're
going to get like killed and stuffed
into a [__] box. I What do you want
me to tell you? I'm sorry. Exact
opposite. I just laugh and giggle. I
don't know.
>> I am generally polite. I'm generally
polite. I think it's kindness.
Honesty is the best policy and kindness
is good or whatever. What's that saying?
Honesty is the best policy or something.
Something like that. Some random
homeless person on a bike followed me to
work and I just laughed until teenagers
scared him by throwing rocks. Wow. Epic.
Feel I feel um I feel kind of sad. I
wish I had more like like life stories.
I wish I had more life stories. I wish I
had more tales I could tell. I I like I
I kind of want to go to like college or
something just so I get cool stories.
Just so I can get cool stories to tell.
So I can be like when I was in college
when I was in college this happened.
you. Oh, go to college. That's what I'm
That's what I've been thinking. I've
been thinking I go to college. Every one
good story, you get like a 100 bad ones.
Oh, sure. True. I mean, I have a lot of
bad stories. I don't think I'd ever want
to tell them on stream, though.
Actually, do I have a bad story? I can
tell on Let me think.
Probably not. Um,
I kind of like fights at school. I like
I just got like beat the [__] up. Uh,
but I won I won one fight. I think I won
one of the fights. So, it's kind of like
kind of I kind of I kind of won that.
You need to live in a city and not
Idaho. I don't like cities. I I went to
LA for vacation.
I should say California more broadly. I
went to California for vacation and it
was not nice. I didn't like it.
I didn't like it. I don't like cities. I
uh prefer rural areas to be honest.
That's just me. That's me. I don't know
if I can tell any any bad stories on
stream. I feel like they're all like um
when I was driving one time a the wheel
fell off my car, I guess. Is that a bad
story? I kind of like funny, I guess. Um
yeah, the the like [__] who is like the
front left tire like just fell off my
car. It was a good story. That's a good
story. You guys like that? How um [__] I
forget how. Um, it was like something
broke. Like the something broke. Like it
snapped off. It broke off. It didn't
like the screws didn't f It wasn't the
screws. It was like the actual metal.
Like something it was like a
catastrophic failure or something.
Whatever they called it. It wasn't l No,
it was not loose. Um or anything like
that. I don't know if I have a lot of
bad stories. Oh, Jordan responded to my
DM. Are you down for a call or would you
prefer text? PLDDR liio use you for
pedobate
i.e. tell you to message adults or
engage with uh adults
in text that were attempting to prey on
you etc.
Okay. They responded being sassy. This
[__] [__] better not better [__]
calm down or Jesus. Jesus Christ. I
don't have a lot of life stories. I
don't even have a lot of bad stories. I
feel like I just I'm pretty boring. I
don't know. My memor is also [__] I
feel like if anything if anything
happened to me, I probably would have
freaking forgotten it. Oh, actually, a
[__] A couple days ago, my my window
was open and it has like the screen and
my cat was outside and um it like it
jumped in and broke through the [__]
screen. Like it ripped the screen open
like at the you know where it's kind of
connected at the bottom and like the
sides of the metal. It like ripped open
that and like jumped through my window
like into my room and it scared the [__]
out of me. That was funny. No. Oh yeah,
they said no. So I don't know where that
is coming from.
I don't know where that's coming from.
All that digging for a basis claim. At
least you made money. True. All right.
Yeah. Well, I think we're going to end.
I think we're going to end.
We've been going 11 and a half hours. I
tried to stay up to research that claim,
but it Yeah, ultimately it seems like it
was baseless. Um, nobody's live. You
already watch Auggie ripping a Willie
Mac. Um, no, I have not. I was going to
watch it today, but I got derailed with
Lio [__] Well, the stream was about I I
had planned on watching that, but I got
derailed into looking into Lio more than
I initially was. All right, nobody to
raid. I'm going to end. I don't know if
it'll be live tomorrow. I said that
yesterday and I went live today. I'm not
sure. We'll see. Maybe I'll watch the
Auggie [__] tomorrow. That could be fun.
Um I I am working on another video. I
don't want to say what it's about
because I don't I feel like an issue
with the Cameron video and even the
glass video. I feel like just because I
talk about it on stream so much, it like
hypes it up and people um people get too
excited and I feel like I I don't, you
know, make the video to expectations or
whatever and people ultimately are
disappointed. So, I probably won't talk
about the video. I probably will like
drop it and then talk about it on stream
after the fact, but I am working on a
new video. I am pretty excited for it.
I'm taking in all the criticisms that I
got from the Cameron video. I'm writing
jokes. I'm writing jokes in it. Okay.
There are jokes in it.
Okay. There are jokes in it. I'm writing
jokes because people wanted me to be
funny. Can write jokes on demand if I
really hate the person. Yeah, I think I
don't know. I'm not really that good at
it. I don't think I'm like particularly
funny on demand. I don't even know if
I'm funny in general. People say I am. I
just trust them. I trust them at their
word. Okay.
I trust them at their word.
Uh yeah, but I'm going to end off. Um
what is the what is the message I should
leave you guys with? Don't debate women
on Hinge and don't
talk to women about Fallout 2 because
generally speaking,
uh, that doesn't end well. That's all. I
don't have I don't have a lot. All
right, I'll raid into this random
VTuber. I'll see you guys later. Bye
bye. Thank you for the donos and the
memberships. I appreciate it. I